there are places all over the world
where methane is coming out of the
seafloor
this is kind of concerning because
methane is a very strong greenhouse gas
we think a lot about carbon dioxide
heating up the planet but nothing is
about 25 times worse anything we could
do to understand where that methane is
coming from and where it might be going
is really important these samples are
really rare really exciting and we gotta
preserve as much of the real story as
possible we focus a lot on how humans
are causing climate change and that's a
real problem but we don't even
understand that the full scope of the
natural world to begin with to collect
these samples we have Alvin Alvin is a
human occupied submersible that goes
down about 1400 metres below the sea
level should pick up a chunk of the sea
floor to analyze back in the lab have a
great day one of the main things we were
after on this expedition was the
sediments right around these methane
seas
[Music]
microwaves are the smallest type of
living organism on the planet and these
aren't the first line of defense of
keeping methane for coming out of the
sea floor into the atmosphere
the microbes inside the rocks are in the
sediment are eating the methane and
that's really important from this
greenhouse gas perspective to keep that
methane from getting into the water and
eventually getting into the atmosphere
where it would heat up the planet if
you're pretty dangerous we have a very
rare chance to sample some of the
biology and try to piece together
exactly what's happening
[Music]
as we learn more about how these
microbes are eating methane and how
active they are where exactly this is
happening we can understand what's
happening with our planet and how to
prevent greenhouse gases from entering
the atmosphere this process takes
several months but it looks like they're
pretty active they're eating methane
which is a good sign this idea that the
world is so expansive on a microbial
scale is really exciting by chasing
microbes to the ends of different
possibilities we're finding what life is
capable
[Music]